support booth University in the
production of more videos by visiting
the link in the description below where
you'll find more details thank you and
enjoy next up is the gold foil
experiment by Ernest Rutherford in 1911
where he discovered the atomic nucleus
his experiment was pretty significant
because it disproved the plum pudding
model by proving the existence of a
small dense positively charged nucleus
at the center of the atom so how did he
do that what was his sort of setup and
not me observe and conclude all that he
concluded well he set up his apparatus
that had an alpha emitter which shot
alpha particles at a thin strip of gold
foil okay shot at a thin strip of gold
foil and around this gold foil was this
circular screen that would basically
detect the alpha particles by giving off
a flash of light when it was hit by that
off particle so I said the Alpha chord
alpha particle and the words alpha
particle a few times now and I haven't
really even talked about what it is an
alpha particle is a small positively
charged particle that is much smaller
than an atom but seven thousand times
bigger than an electron so an alpha
particle specifically are have a
positively positive two charge okay so
what happened was they shot they took
this alpha emitter and it had a shot
alpha particle had this really thin
strip of gold foil and what I really
know what what did they notice so what
happened so well a lot of the particles
went straight through and there was a
lot of detection on the screen right
back here right tons back here and there
were some some situations in which it
lit up over here and and over here so
and it was kind of crazy is that there
were some some cases in which the
detection was over here or even back
here
so they notice that most of the flashes
were directly behind the gold foil
directly behind the gold foil which
meant that basically that alpha
particles were going straight through
straight through the gold foil and to
the other side right so what did
Rutherford conclude based on that
observation based on that observation
they concluded that they concluded that
the atom is mostly empty space if these
particles are just traveling straight
through the atom must mostly be empty
space um but what he did notice is that
there were very few one in every 20,000
drastic deflections or major deflections
so there was some that were pretty that
might have been pretty minor where you
know if you notice instead of all of
them went straight in a straight line
there might have been some that came off
like this or like this but there were
some that came pretty much back in the
direction where the alpha particles came
from so that was kind of crazy and so
the conclusion that they drew from that
was that there must be a tiny dense
positively charged nucleus deflecting
the alpha particles so let's think about
why this would be the conclusion based
on the hypothesis the hypothesis was
based off of the the plum pudding model
okay the plum pudding model so the plum
pudding atoms look like this right where
they have that positively charged fluff
positively charged fluff and these
electrons so the hypothesis was that if
we shoot if he shoots alpha particles at
this thin this thin gold foil this
gopher was supposed to be a few atoms
thick right so if we think about these
just being the actual gold atoms sort of
aligning themselves like this shooting
these alpha particles at them if the
plum pudding model is the case right
that's if that's what atoms actually
look
then these these particles should go
straight through why is that well
because these electrons if they're like
the dense particles that are contained
within an atom but there's 7,000 times
smaller than the alpha particle then the
alpha particle should have no problem
sort of running right through these
these electrons it's kind of like the
way I imagine it is like a bowling ball
being launched at a tiny like poppy seed
or like a bee bee or something right if
you think about the alpha particle being
the bowling ball and the electrons being
7000 times smaller like the size of like
I said a little BB or a tiny tiny ball
then those that the tiny ball is not
going to deflect the bowling ball
anywhere right so most of them should go
straight through
so that was a hypothesis because it was
based on the plum pudding model so when
they saw that there was deflections like
this where the the alpha particle would
actually go backwards in the direction
that it came from that was pretty crazy
to them that was pretty crazy that this
that these that this situation even
happened so what that led them to
believe is that there must have been
something in the atom that was dense
enough and large enough to deflect the
alpha particle backwards so the actual
result led to what was called the
nuclear model which will actually talk
about in the next video but I'll kind of
show what the result look like here just
a moment actually
so they reason that there must be
something tiny dense and positively
charged at the center of the atom like
this such that the the alpha particles
would come in and most of them would go
straight through but there would be some
cases in which the alpha particle would
come in bump into something tiny and
dense and deflect off like this maybe I
should
different color should or just circle it
see how this is kind of directed off off
course right and this one if it if it
hits the right way it can actually be
directed backwards right or this one
kind of being knocked off course so
since there were so few of these drastic
deflections that that led to the idea
that it must have been pretty small it's
been a tiny tiny dense situation in
there and because these alpha particles
have a +2 charge it would that that
positive what used to be the positive
fluff is not actually positive fluff in
the pudding model it must be a
positively charged particles there and
so he called this little entity at the
center of the atom a nucleus okay
deflecting the alpha particles and it
makes sense that if it's positively
charged that these these it would repel
a positively charged alpha particle so
Rutherford basically concluded that the
nucleus must contain small positively
charged particles
he called protons so he developed a
nuclear nuclear model of the atom which
will see like I said in the next video I
hope that video is helpful thank you for
watching you found that video helpful be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
content also follow move University on
the different social media links in the
description below thank you and happy
studying